OR THURSDAY
FEBRUARY TENTH TWENTY TWENTY TWO
IS HEREBY CALLED ORDER. YOUR
VISOR AUDIO VIDEO RECORDING OF
TODAY'S PROCEED IS BEING MADE
AND IS ALSO BEING TELEVISED
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC ATTENDING
THIS HEARING MUST WEAR A MASK AT
ALL TIMES. ATTENDEES MUST ALSO
REFRAIN FROM ANY CONDUCT THAT
DISRUPTS DISTURBS OR OTHERWISE
IMPEDES THE ORDERLY CONDUCT OF
THIS HEARING. VIOLATIONS OF
THESE RULES VERY SUBJECTED
INDIVIDUALS REMOVAL OR OTHER
ENFORCEMENT PROCESS. ARE MISTER
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
COOLEY HERE CUNNINGHAM BENNETT
BONTA FLORA GIPSON HERE LEAVE
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS RAMOS RUBIO.
BE ROCK HERE WE HAVE QUORUM WE
HAVE A CORE WE HAVE A CONSENT.
UBER MISTER GIPSON SECONDED OF
MY FLOOR. OF MR SEARCH PLEASED
THE ROLL COOLEY HI COOLEY
CUNNINGHAM AT. BENNETT HI BONTA
FLORA FLORA I GIPSON GIPSON HI
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN I'M-
RAMOS RAMOS I RUBIO. RUBIO IV
APPROVED BY THE APPROVED BY
MOTION PASSES THANK YOU VERY
MUCH COLLEAGUES OVER HERE MORE.
THEIR CONTENT AND THEN THE WEEK
I MEAN ARE WELL THE- OUR- RIGHT
I HATE.
REFLECTOR JANET MATHIS
FIVE MATHIS. THANK YOU SIR THANK
YOU CAN. THIS RULES COMMITTEE
IS ADJOURNED